[Music]
she'll Burke is stepping in for Abby Lee
Miller on Dance Moms and it only takes
one hot second for things to explode
during Abby's final appearance on the
show why are you back you don't want to
work with the kids they don't want to
work with you you screwed it up
that's might be the last time we ever
say this place in March Dance Moms
infamous drill sergeant told me she quit
because she felt disrespected by the
show I'm finished working under these
conditions
believe me are you while Abby says her
tearful goodbyes in the upcoming season
Cheryl gets quite the welcome have you
seen the news Cheryl that you're
replacing Abby Lee Miller they didn't
trust Abby to be with their girls I'm
not going to yell at them you can't
remember to turn your feet up I'm not
going to judge them for their
appearances you're bowlegged
I don't like her way of teaching I don't
think she's replacing me I think it's
gonna be a different vibe and I bet you
she's treated differently a dance mom
sourced lzt once Sheryl was put in place
the production breathed the sigh of
relief I don't think one of them I don't
need any of them after her reality show
exit in March Abby's life got even more
dramatic you feel glad that at least
it's over I think it's just begun last
month the 50 year old was sentenced to a
year in a day in federal prison for
bankruptcy fraud are you prepared to
spend time in prison though she also
underwent risky gastric sleeve surgery
there's nobody freaking out if something
happens to me and in this last Dance
Moms appearance expect one more tearful
hurrah I regret it oh my god everything
she does have those tears flowing a lot
doesn't she I'm sure there's gonna be
more tears at the end of this month when
Abby is expected to check into prison
[Music]
you